hein alors écoutez maintenant je vais
vous demander une chose hein je vais
vous demander votre collaboration
directe voilà vous allez voir euh je je
vais pas vous expliquer tout le
mécanisme maintenant je suppose que vous
connaissez plus ou moins la chanson on
va chanter doroté ensemble et ça
consiste en ceci c'est que le metteur le
metteur le meneur le meneur de jeu
c'està-dire votre serviteur dites une
chose et l'assistance c'est-à-dire vous
reprends hein alors vous allez pas me
lâcher n'est-ce pas hein vous allez bien
reprendre d'une seule voix mes chers
concitoyens vous allez me donner vos
voix ti on se reporte un mois en avant
alors attention vous allez voir comment
ça se passe on peut on donne un tout
petit exemple avec les musiciens et tout
suite après c'est bien vous he attention
vous êtes
prêt alors vous êtes prêt
pr voyez quand vous voulez vous êtes des
jeunes gens bien élevés alors attention
ah
miaou très bien alors attention ça à
vous vous SIG
ah
ah attendez écoutez je me crois une
petite voie personnelle je voudrais
faire faire miaou par mon ancien
proviseur monsieur leiseur très
respectueusement est-ce que je peux
prendre la liberté de vous demander de
faire mia avec
moi attention quelle revanche 20 ans
après comme dans comme dans l'exandre
duain attention miaou miaou et
bien
ah l'existence vous procure de ces
sortes de joie alors attention
ah ador tes bonnes filles c'est pas toi
qui dirait non je trouve bien gentil un
pe
trop
blanc
noirtoi il te dit
embrasse-moi
Arve on est etand on la
attention
ile attention maintenant beaucoup plus
difficile alors maintenant de plus en
plus difficile niveau du bacalora 2è
partie avant la
réforme très difficile seul les
personnes qui ont un dentier mal su sont
dispensés de l'exercice alors regardez
tout dans le
masque
attention
exécution alors alors toute une armée de
dentier pour tout le
monde c'est pas toi qui dira non pas
inventé l'au chaude mais que
B
BL
no
embrasse-moi
à Joh pass
h
tout seul on est
tous
attention